able to talk while I'm wearing it yes
strato be distract okay is that an issue
the fact that you are disarm just
getting a message right now it is it can
be an issue I actually in my review what
I was saying is that what I've
discovered is that you know I think if
you think you're gonna put this on and
it's gonna somehow alleviate that
problem you've got with your phone where
you're always taking it on looking at it
just moves that to another place so
you've got to beat you have some
self-control when you've got this on
what do you think that we already
understand their aunt lines there aren't
queues outside regent street outside
comic-con and London of course they want
you to buy this device online but do you
think people have to try it test it put
it on before they gonna buy I think
people have to be convinced they need it
I think the biggest problem is you know
you need a phone when the new iPhone
comes out you're like well I'm going to
upgrade I'm gonna get the newest best
phone this is something that a lot of
people don't even wear watches so you've
got to be convinced that you need
something exactly you need something on
your wrist and I don't know that Apple's
done that job yet I think over time
people will discover its features and
want to want to get one but it's a
little bit of a tough sell right now is
it the world's best small watch yes or
no absolutely and does that say a lot
about the competition or does that say
more about the watch itself well the
competition now has something better to
copy I think that's important I look
Apple is known for taking a product
category that exists and making the best
version of it that's not unusual for
them as a company so they've done that
in the watch but this is a space that's
its nascent barely exists right now so
it wasn't hard to make something much
better because there's only a few decent
products on the market and they seem to
be just catching the wave of it as it
starts to build up we're expecting far
more smartwatches to sell this year but
what's the killer app on there at the
moment probably not yet design but what
yeah as it stands do you like the most
apart from try not to be distracted I
think that aight for me the killer app
is that on the watch face itself you get
all of these little they call them
complications and you can put the
weather there you can put your next
calendar appointment there you can put
the phases of the Moon I've actually
found that incredibly useful for when
i'm on my way out the door and grabbing
my jacket what's the temperature what's
my next appointment just this quick
update on what's happening without
having to pull my phone out and check so
i think that for me just the convenience
of all of that information in one place
has been really great all third-party
apps use
us as one critic labeled I wouldn't say
I wouldn't say holy useless but they are
not I mean you're not gonna read Twitter
on your watch I can tell you it's not a
great experience yeah not something I
can see people doing in the future so I
think that that right now the third
parties are trying to figure out what
are we supposed to do with this and
their first attempts have been not
completely successful is it the Apple
isn't sort of holding their hands
through the process enough for example
quite willing for their apps to be the
dominant force for the time being yeah I
think it might be a little of both but
also it's just it's such a new interface
there's so many new ways of interacting
with the watch that it's it's kind of
hard to conceive of what an app should
be like for it right now what about the
panic over the battery life Joshua okay
played or not I had no panic over
battery life but I charge my phone every
night if you're a person who doesn't put
their phone on a charger this isn't for
you because you've got to put it on a
charger every time you you get into bed
what I was lucky people who don't put
the phone on a child I don't know I
don't know they must be very relaxed
that's all I can say but but if you
charge it every night I didn't think
about the battery life throughout the
day it was not an issue in your in your
bin your piece which I read if he ate a
few days ago Joshua you said that you
have to remove the wrist for it to come
on and often it doesn't come on when you
move the wrist yeah that that's the
problem isn't it it's look ninety
percent of the time it works fine but
when you're trying to check the time or
check some information quickly and
you've got that too that ten percent
window where it is blank it's very
frustrating because you know when you're
in a rush and you're saying well okay
with more times that I gotta get out the
door so the valency the mystical watch
is to be able to tell the time that you
can do with a Rolex exactly and for ten
percent of the time you can't do it was
that was what that was one of my first
observations was wait a second this
isn't coming on I've got to do this
really kind of exaggerated sometimes to
get the thing to come to life very
subtle in the other is not acceptable
that's the thing is it's not subtle and
and a watch does one thing really well
all the time which is keep the time so
this is a struggling a little bit in
that department so I'm guessing that
you're a bit of an addict when it comes
to getting then the latest thing is that
is that why you bought it or was it you
just wanted to know this was a nice
Apple wanted you know it handed a few of
these out for review
was one of the lucky people on the list
you know the quiet but then the question
becomes I've been thinking the whole
time what would I go to a storm by this
the version I test it was a thousand
dollars it's hard to imagine going to
spend a thousand dollars on a watch that
that in a year will be there'll be a new
version of it cuz that's my tactic right
I'm gonna leave it for the next
iteration yeah I want Apple to work with
this is that we is it gonna be a bit
like a tablet like the first one Art's a
bit clunky but I pad then third one
you've got to get it yeah I think I do
think there's gonna be some early
adopters the people who like I will
probably end up going to buy one anyhow
because I just like having the new shiny
thing but I do think some people are
gonna have their gonna wait to be
convinced for that second or will it
ever replace your typical watch your
Rolex pacifico I didn't even wear a
watch so I do love watches traditional
watches um I don't know I don't know yet
it's a tough 1i I actually I'm torn
because I want to go back to my watch
that I where normally which is a
beautiful will you how soon uh I'm not
sure yet I feel like I'm still testing I
don't know you're not wedded to it I'm
not wedded to it but I'm not quite ready
to take it off uh-huh like a girlfriend
you don't short you're not sure about
yeah it could go either way yeah break
up or you could head to the altar wife
oh well girlfriend but I know I working
yeah why don't you just lose you a
little bit more him that's exactly what
I need some willing watch